drew barrymore loving her show by the
way she had the sweetest surprise for
one huge fan on thursday's episode of
the drew bear more show take a look have
a great weekend
so i'm here with my friend victoria and
our friend kelly was supposed to come
with us but she's actually studying for
finals and you're literally like her
favorite celebrity so i want to ask you
if you'd mind facetiming her of course
give her mine
i hope she picks up
we'll see if we are we oh hi
welcome to the show kelly we're so
bummed that you can't be here
wait okay so what are you doing right
now
i'm just studying for my finals oh wait
what
how's it going what are you feeling the
most confident in and what do you think
you need to study more
oh um
so i have a final critique for my art
project tomorrow but i have to study for
my history class like
not going well okay well literally just
study as if your life depends on it
and then tomorrow you can kick back and
the best time to rest is when you know
you crushed it as hard as you could
and
may i please send you a ticket to come
to the show as soon as you're done
studying
your friend jen is a really good friend
and look there's your other friend so we
have an invitation and a ticket waiting
for you as soon as you're done studying
[Applause]
all right i'll see you soon